(revving engine)
(atmospheric music)
(radio communication)
- [Alison Laroza] The most
unique part of rally car racing
is, if a regular person were
to hear the in-car audio
of a driver and a co-driver,
it would seem like they
were speaking gibberish.
(car engine revving)
Right four long turn left five tightens
three minus no cut.
In actuality it's a language
that tells that driver
what is coming next.
Right five minus 100.
They really are just
the eyes for the driver
before they can get to that spot.
Rally car racing in
America is stage racing.
You can have anywhere
from 12 to 14 stages,
anywhere from six to
20 miles in some cases.
I mean you're racing other competitors,
but really it's you against the clock.
(pulsing tech music)
So inside of a rally
car, we have two people.
We have a driver and a co-driver.
The driver drives the car,
tries to keep it on the
road, without wrecking it.
And the co-driver is responsible
for reading the notes.
- [Alison] 50 turn a left three
tighten right three minus,
no cut.
So for this example, we have 50 here,
so that means before the next note I call
you'll have 50 meters.
And then T for me stands for turn,
which means you'll change
roads from the road
that you're currently on.
And then a left three.
Left obviously means your
corner's gonna go to the left.
And a three is the degree of the corner.
- [Steve] There's so
much information to take
in from the co-driver, in
say 120 miles over a weekend,
it could be as many as
two to three thousand
different commands that
co-driver is reading the driver.
Pretty much that co-driver
is the computer of that car.
He or she is gonna get you
from point A to point B.
And as a driver, you
need to trust what that
co-driver is telling you.
- [Alison] We started
as a team when I was 15,
and sometimes I feel like
I can simply read his mind.
Six and twenty,
left six over (inaudible).
- [Steve] I really trust
what she is telling me,
to the point where if
I had to close my eyes
and maybe not drive at race speed,
she could tell me, pacenotes,
and I could still drive blind.
- [Alison] Into left
three, into right four.
Right four long up, tightens
at T to a right two,
break turn, left three off camber, 40,
into a care left three down,
50 turn left three tightens
into a right three minus...
(atmospheric music)
(car engine revving)
- [Steve] Rallies let me see how one
of my children has grown up
and how they've become.
If I looked at her as a
co-driver and not a daughter
or a relative, I'd grab
her in a heartbeat.
- [Alison] I'd love to make
it a full time career one day
and rally internationally.
And I'd love to just follow
in my Dad's footsteps.